hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
we've been doing a lot of like career
tips professional development advice
tech industry things on my channel and
here's another one for starters if
you're in a fortunate enough position
where you're considering between
different opportunities and different
jobs then congratulations you made it
this video is for you you might have
multiple competing offers for different
companies or you could be in interview
processes for multiple companies and you
just want to be prepared for when you
have to choose point is at the end of
the day you do have to make a choice and
it's not just any choice it's a choice
that will decide how you spend your
mornings and your day to day for
hopefully years and years to come it's a
big deal and the fact that you can only
choose one makes this decision that much
harder so before i dive into like my
huge spiel about like tips and tricks on
how to choose jobs let me just say
beforehand that i'm a big believer and
what's supposed to happen will happen
what i'm trying to say by that is that
there's no inherently right or wrong
decision there's only the decision that
you make with your own best interests in
mind you make your own life your own
destiny and your own future so whatever
you choose will truly be the right
choice i just hope that took a tiny bit
of pressure off your hands because i
know it's hard before we get started i
want to say a quick thank you to career
karma for sponsoring today's video
career karma is the easiest place to
find a us-based job training program
online they help over 1 million workers
navigate their careers every month
offering support through a community of
peers mentors and coaches to find your
dream career and attending a job
training program like a boot camp is the
best way to quickly switch to a tech
career that affords a six-figure salary
work from home flexibility and high job
satisfaction i myself have people close
to me who went to bootcamps who were
able to make the career switch into
technology so i highly recommend looking
into them so if you're interested then
you should be on career camera it's free
and you'll never ever have to pay for
anything you find on there the first 000
of my subscribers get exclusive free
early access to career karma's new mini
coding bootcamp go to ck dot chat myuco
to get started thank you so much again
to career karma for sponsoring and now
back to the video anyways i'm going to
outline for you all the factors that i
considered when choosing paths as a
software engineer these are the things
that helped steered me towards different
directions as i went about through my
career so as a prerequisite to all of
this i really think it's important to
think about what do you want from this
opportunity what do you want from your
next job is it just the paycheck or are
you exciting that it's your first step
in the door to the tech industry is this
somewhere you really want to grow in in
the next phase of your career are there
people that you can look up to or admire
that you could really learn from once
you know what you really want out of it
then looking at each job opportunity
will just kind of be a matter of like
seeing which puzzle piece fits the
puzzle that you want to create the
bottom line to all this is that i really
encourage you to look at each
opportunity from multiple different
perspectives what i'll call like the
lenses for this video try to identify
pros and cons from across the board from
every perspective you can think of then
look over the data that you collected
and see if the choice is obvious and you
know if it's not then go with your heart
so let's start with a big determining
factor for looking at any job no matter
how much you might want it or whether
you want it for other reasons it's the
money this is after all what's going to
support your livelihood as you work this
job and in a place like america it's a
non-trivial factor so is the
compensation you're being offered good
enough for you one way to answer this
question is to ask yourself does it
allow you to comfortably live the life
that you want to recently my brother
went through all this as he went for his
first like full-time role as a ux
designer and we literally like tried to
plot out how much it would cost for him
to do life all in one spreadsheet we
scoped out all the costs for standard
things like rent and food and insurance
and utilities and gas based on the city
that he wanted to live in because yes
the city makes a huge difference for
prices on stuff like this and in cases
where we didn't really know what the
exact number was going to be we just
needed a ballpark and so we googled
around things like rent prices and gas
prices for that area and took an average
this stuff is important because well
you're gonna spend a lot of time at your
job how you live outside of your job is
going to impact how you perform at it if
that makes sense not to mention i think
it's kind of important to like enjoy
your life outside of work and to be
happy with your living situation you
know so when considering an offer beyond
things like the immediate living
situation stuff
also consider whether that compensation
is going to help you to meet your
long-term life goals or financial goals
too like what's next for you on your
priority list moving to a big city or
maybe buying a car or even a house maybe
it's financial independence from your
family for the first time everyone's
answer here is gonna be totally
different because we all want different
things in life and also your tolerance
level for money and risk and stuff is
also gonna probably be different from
mine say some are okay with not saving a
lot in favor of like a bump in their
quality of life immediately others want
to maximize that number in their savings
account and that's also okay too and
remember the offer contains more than
just the dollar amount for your salary
it's really the whole package that comes
along with working there so things like
is it remote work if it's an office that
you can commute to is it a comfortable
place to work is your commute super long
maybe it's close by in an area that you
like also do you get equity and if so
how long does it take for you to vest
that equity how much vacation time do
you get do you have to accrue that time
what about the perks sometimes things
like a gym membership or a
transportation credit get thrown in and
how much do these things actually matter
to you all this requires a bit of
projecting for what you might want your
life to look like before you actually
start doing so so have a bit of
imagination with this and see if the
components of the offer fit your needs
so even before you get an offer probably
at the interview stage you're thinking
about things like do you know this
company do you respect them and the work
that they do have you used their product
and do you like it most simply after you
get the offer think about are you
excited by the idea of working there of
course it's a great bonus if you're like
their biggest fan but you don't need to
go basing your choices around stuff like
that it's really only important that you
like it enough and that you feel like
you'll be challenged and stimulated
while working there and that you're
going to have an appreciation for the
work that you do of course not all jobs
are like exciting from the get-go so one
helpful thing to think about is whether
this job is going to afford you
opportunities in the future like some
people really want to travel for work
and some companies actually have
programs for stuff like that other
people want to climb the ladder and
become an executive someday and if so
are there good mentorship programs or is
there a good direct line of
communication with the people in the
upper field so that you can plan for the
long term and if you don't know exactly
what you want is there at least a little
bit of freedom to explore so that you
can figure that out just make sure that
when you're thinking about this stuff to
think about it also realistically no
company is perfect and there are gonna
be days where it feels like a grind
literally for any job there are going to
be hard days so maybe think about like
what a hard day at this job would look
like is there likely to be some politics
within an organization do layoffs happen
in here and what kinds of struggles are
you uncomfortable dealing with at work
i'm just mentioning this because i've
been disillusioned by companies that i
thought were like brilliant shining
places to work with noble missions and
then reality just hit me hard i just
wish that i had been a little bit more
realistic in my thinking about what it's
like to work there so that when [ __ ]
happens i wouldn't be so heartbroken no
i'm definitely not saying that those
things are gonna happen to you per se my
positive experience definitely
outweighed the negative ones a job is
still a job and while every day might
not be fine there's a lot of fun and
positivity and learning that comes from
one so i just think it's really
important to be prepared and then open
to all of the goodness that can come
so as you really start to consider all
of your options think about your
feelings too like how do you feel right
now about the thought of working for
this company are you happy about the
offer would you be happy if you joined
this company what about a month into the
job or six months or a year in does the
idea of that scare you or excite you by
the way being scared is okay like we're
meant to do hard things fear to me is
really just a signal that you're
stretching yourself out of your comfort
zone and at a very core and basic and
instinctual level does it feel right to
you you'll know what that means when you
ask yourself
so consider all these three lenses
the offer the company or the product and
how you feel about this and there's a
lot of other different lenses too that
might be specific to your situation so
try to find those lenses to look from
again i really recommend writing a list
of pros and cons for each of the
opportunities that you're considering if
you have multiple offers then this makes
it really easy to visualize which one's
the better choice and with all that
information in your hands hopefully
things will be clearer maybe the process
of gathering that information is really
what you need because remember the
choice that you make with the right
information and with your heart will be
the right one thank you all so much for
watching today's video i really hope you
liked it maybe you're struggling with
this decision or maybe you know someone
who is i'd really love it if you'd share
this video with them and if you're on
the receiving end of that hi welcome you
have such a nice run i've made a lot of
other videos about the job process
specifically about the tech industry so
if you're interested in those videos
then check them out in the description
box down below and make sure to
subscribe to my channel in a members
only video i'm talking about how i chose
all of my jobs throughout my software
engineering career and what factors
weighed into each of them so if you're
interested in watching that then come
join the club by clicking the join
button down below and getting access for
as low as 99 cents a month i've been
making a lot of members only videos to
go along with like the main videos that
are free to you all but becoming a
member just helps me around my channel
and shows me support so i really
appreciate it alright everybody hope you
have a great day and i'll see you next
time bye